สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ค่ะนะขอต้อนรับทุกคนนะคะเข้าสู่ห้องเรียน
comprehensible  Thai ห้องเรียนภาษาไทย
ค่ะนะแล้วก็เรียนแบบธรรมชาติธรรมชาติกับ
ครูปุ๊กครูชิค่ะในวันนี้เนี่ยวันอะไรคะ
ครูชิวันนี้เป็นวันจันทร์ค่ะสี
เหลืองแต่ทำไมเสื้อครูไม่เหลืองเลยนะก็
เป็นวันจันทร์หน้าเหลือง
ค่ะไม่สบายหรือ
เปล่านะวันนี้วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 16 ค่ะค่ะเดือนอะไรคะตุลาคมค่ะค่ะ
เป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเดือนที่ 10 ค่ะ
ค่ะปีพุทธศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะ
2566 เป็นปีคริสตศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะ
2023 ค่ะค่ะนะวันนี้ก็มาเจอครูปุ๊กครูชิ
ในวันจันทร์ที่ 16 เดือนตุลาคมนะคะปี
พุทธศักราช
2566 ปีคริสตศักราช
2023 ค่ะค่ะแล้ววันนี้ครูชินะคะก็มาอยู่
ที่ตลาดค่ะโอ้โหครูชิาครูชีทำให้ครููปุ๊ก
หิว
ค่ะหิวครูปุ๊กตอนเนี้ยโอ้โหครูปุ๊กจะเห็น
ว่าที่ตลาดที่ประเทศไทยตอนนี้มันจะติดธง
สีเหลืองเต็มไปหมดเลยค่ะโอ้โหเ้าติดไว้
ทำไมคะครูชิสีเหลือธงสีเหลืองเนี่ยข้างบน
เนี่ยปกติเคติดธงสีเหลืองแล้วเขาเขียนว่า
เจนะเจเขียนเป็นภาษาจีนสีแดงว่าใจหรือ
ภาษาไทยว่าเจนี่แหละ
ค่ะนะแล้วเจเมันเกี่ยวอะไรกันน่ะคะครูชิ
ช่วงนี้เป็นช่วงเทศกาลกินเจค่ะแล้วเเริ่ม
กินตั้งแต่เมื่อวานนี้มาแล้วค่ะวันที่ 15
อ๋อครูก็ได้ยินมาว่าเค้าเริ่มกินจริงๆน่ะ
เมื่อวานแต่บางคนบอกว่าไม่ได้ค่ะถ้ากิน
เมื่อวานเลยเนี่ยเดี๋ยวข้างในยังมีพวกหมู
พวกเนื้อสัตว์ยังอยู่ไม่ดีอาจจะกินมาก่อน
ตั้งแต่วันที่ 14 ก็ได้บางคนบอกว่าโอ๊ย 13
เลยก็ได้ค่ะนะกินมาก่อนเลยค่ะแต่วันเอ่อ
วันที่เนี่ยมันจะไม่ตรงกันทุกปีนะเพราะ
ว่าเค้าจะดูพระจันทร์ค่ะนะนักเรียนบอก
Full  Moon ปาร์ตี้หรือเปล่าไม่ใช่นะ
คะคือดูจากดวงจันทร์นี่ใช่มั้ยคะใช่ค่ะดู
จากดวงจันทร์หรือพระจันทร์เนี่ยล่ะค่ะนะ
เวลานับเนี่ยก็เลยไม่ตรงกันกับวันที่ปกติ
ในปฏิทินที่เราดูแบบนี้เนาะอันนี้เนี่ย
ปฏิทินแบบเนี้ยมันก็เลยไม่ตรงวันจะบอกว่า
กินเจตรงกับวันที่เท่าไหร่เนี่ยไม่ได้
ต้องเปลี่ยนทุกปีค่ะต้องเช็คในปฏิทิน
อย่างนี้ค่ะว่าเป็น
วันกินเจสำหรับปฏิทินจีนเนาะก็จะมีเลยแน่
นอนเป็นวันขึ้น 1 ค่ำเดือน 9 ใช่มั้ยคะ
หรือเดือน 10 เดือน 9 ของจีนค่ะของไทย
เนี่ยนะเดือน 10 อืไทยอาจจะ 10  11 แล้ว
มั้นะของนักเรียนน่ะต่างชาติก็จะเป็นว
เดือนที่ 10 ใช่มั้ยอันเนี้ยเวลานับจะปวด
หัวนิดหน่อยค่ะเดือนเนี่ยเพราะว่าเดือน
แบบจีนเดือนแบบไทยเดือนแบบฝรั่งเนี่ยไม่
เหมือนกันค่ะนะใช่นะคะก็จะไม่ไม่ว่ามัน
ตรงกับเอ่อวันไหนนะคะก็เราก็จะเริ่มกินเจ
ในวันนั้นในปีเนี้ยปี
2566 เนี่ยวันกินแจหรือวันขึ้น 1 ค่ำ
เดือน 9 ใช่มยตรงกับวันที่ 15 เพราะ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยก็จะเริ่มกินเจกันวันที่ 15
นี้นะแล้วก็กินต่อกันไปจนถึงวันที่ 23
ใช่มยอืใช่ค่ะบางคนอาจจะกินไปถึง 24 ก็
ได้นะเพื่อให้แบบเอ่อนะยังยังบางที่อาจจะ
ยังมีขายอยู่เนาะก็อาจจะกินต่อไปได้เนาะ
แล้วก็เป็นช่วงที่โอ้โหคนที่อยากกินเจเ
เนี่ยจะมีอาหารให้เลือกกินเยอะมากเลยค่ะ
ูชิ
ค่ะทีเนี้ยการกินเจในประเทศไทยค่ะนัก
เรียนเป็นเทศกาลเราต้องบอกว่าเป็นเทศกาล
เทศกาลนึงที่แบบใหญ่ยิ่งใหญ่เหมือนกัน
เพราะอะไรเพราะว่าคนจีนที่มาอยู่ในเมือง
ไทยเนี่ยมีเยอะนะคะเพราะว่าคนจีนมาเมือง
ไทยตั้งแต่อยุธยาค่ะค่ะแล้วก็หลายๆคน
เนี่ยมานะอยู่ประเทศไทยเลยแล้วก็มีแต่ง
งานมีลูกมีหลานก็เลยเป็นคนไทยที่เป็น
เชื้อสายจีนเนี่ยเยอะค่ะ
นะทีนี้เวลากินเจครั้งนึงเนี่ยในแต่ละ
จังวเนี่ยก็จะมีเทศกาลเยิ่งใหญ่ก็จะมี
ขบวนแห่ซึ่งคนก็จะใส่เสื้อสีขาวค่ะแล้วก็
จะโพกผ้าด้วยสีเหลืองมีธงสีเหลืองแล้วก็
เขียนตัวหนังสือเป็นสีแดงนะแล้วก็เป็น
ภาษาจีนค่ะไม่มีภาษาไทยใช่มั้ยคะครูชิไม่
ไม่มีภาษาไทยค่ะไม่ว่าจะเป็นเอ่อเขียน
เป็นจีนแต้จิ๋วเขียนเป็นจีนกลางแล้วแต่
หรือภาคใต้ก็อาจจะเขียนเป็นจีนฮกเกี้ยน
อย่างเงี้ย
นะในแต่ละภาคก็ไม่เหมือนกันนะแล้วแต่จีน
ที่มาในประเทศไทยค่ะนะแล้วก็มีคนจีนหรือ
ว่าคนไทยเสื้อเชื้อสายจีนเนี่ยกินเจกัน
เยอะมากๆเนาะแต่ว่าการเริ่มพิธีเนี่ยเขา
จะดูกันยังไงล่ะคะูชินี่ค่ะในวันที่เริ่ม
กินเจเนี่ยเขาจะมีการตั้งเสาค่ะจะเป็นเสา
ไม้ไผ่ที่สูงมากเจะเอาไม้ไผ่ลำใหญ่ๆค่ะมา
มัดต่อกันสูงแล้วก็ยกขึ้นมาเหมือนเหมือน
กับตรงเนี้ยค่ะยกขึ้นค่ะออต้องจากที่มัน
เงี้ยแล้วก็ตั้งขึ้นมาอย่างงี้ใช่มั้ยยก
ขึ้นมานะก็ตั้งเอาไว้ใช่มยนะเป็นต้นไผ่
เหรอคะที่หมีแพนด้ากินเนี่ยนะใช่ค่ะครู
ปุ๊กแล้วไม่ใช่ลำเดียวบบางทีบางที่เนี่ย 3
บางที่ 4 แล้วก็มีการยึดเอาไว้แล้วแต่เขา
จะเอาขึ้นไปประมาณ 9 ลำค่ะอ๋อต้องต่อต่อ
กันอย่างเงี้ยหรอคะต่อใช่ค่ะ
อ๋อต้องต่อๆกันขึ้นไปเรื่อยๆให้ 9 ลำนะ 1
อันเเรียกว่า 1 ลำใช่มั้ย 1 ต้นเนี่ยอโอ
ก็สูงมากๆเลยสิคะครูชิใช่ค่ะเขาบอกว่า 9
ลำนี้ก็แทนเทพเจ้า 9 องค์ใช่มั้ยคะก็เป็น
เทพประจำวันนี่แหละค่ะออือนะเทพประจำวัน
พุธก็จะมี 2 ใช่มั้ยมีเทพวันพุธกับเทพ
อะไรนะราหูราหูเทพพระเกศล่ะคะวันไหนพระ
เกดเนี่ยเหมือนตรงกลางค่ะไม่ได้อยู่เพราะ
ว่ามันจะมีตารางที่ตีออกมาเป็น 9 ช่องค่ะ
นะเพราะว่าถ้าเกดจะอยู่ตรงกลางแล้วก็
อาทิตย์จันทร์อังคารพุเอย่างเงี้ยนะแล้ว
ก็ไล่ไปตึ๊ดๆๆๆๆๆๆนะคะมันก็เลยเป็นที่มา
ของเสา 9  9 ต้นเนี่ยค่ะใช่ค่ะ
อพอคนเห็นเสาแล้วก็มีธงขึ้นเนี่ยแสดงว่า
อ้าเริ่มกินเจได้แล้วอันนี้เอ่อสัเจ้าจีน
ในประเทศไทยที่มีเยอะแยะเนี่ยก็จะเริ่ม
เทศกาลกินเจเนาะแล้วที่มีชื่อเสียงมากๆใน
การกินเจเนี่ยก็คือจังหวัดภูเก็ตใช่มั้ย
คะกูชิใช่ค่ะเอ่ออย่างอย่าคือในประเทศไทย
เนี่ยมีหลายที่มากนะคะมีทั้ง
นครสวรรค์เยาวราชก็มีค่ะนะคะแต่ที่ขึ้น
ชื่ออย่างที่ครูปุ๊กบอกพอครูปุ๊กบอก
ภูเก็ตเดี๋ยวครูชิพาไปภูเก็ตค่ะนี่ค่ะ
ภูเก็ตโอ้โหนะคะที่ภูเก็ตเนี่ยเอ่อตอน
เนี้ยกูชิว่าน่าจะ 99% ของคนในจังหวัด
ภูเก็ตค่ะที่แต่งชุดขาวแล้วก็กินเจในวัน
ช่วงเทศกาลกิเจค่ะ
อโอแล้วค่ะเค้าเป็นคนจีนกันหมดเลยหรือ
เปล่ากูชิหรือว่าไทยเชื้อสายจีนทั้งหมด
มั้ยก็บางคนเนี่ยมีไทยเชื้อสายจีนนะคคือ
จีนที่เนี่ยจะเป็นจีนฮกเกี้ยนมาแล้วก็จีน
ฮกเกี้ยนเนี่ยเวลากินเจเนี่ยเขาจะมีแบบ
การทำแบบเนี้ยค่ะูกุ๊กเห็นมั้ยแบบมีการ
ใช้เอ่อเหล็กมีการลุยไฟมีการปีนบันไดที่
ทำด้วยมีดนะคะมีดคมๆเนี่ยเอามาหั่นหั่น
อะไรหั่นฟักให้เห็นว่าคมขนาดไหนแล้วก็ปีน
ขึ้นไปค่ะปีนบันไดมีดลุยไฟโอ้โหไฟไม่ใช่
แบบลุยสั้นๆนะลุยยาวเป็นเมตรเลยนะฮก็ไม่
ใช่เป็นเมตรเป็น 10 เมตรค่ะวิ่งวิ่งลุย
กันแบบ
อื้อหือธมเจะเป็นเหมือนว่าอัญเชิญเชิญ
เทพเจ้ามาแล้วก็อยู่ที่คนทรงเนี่ยร่างทรง
ก็คือเป็นคนธรรมดานะแต่ว่าเป็นคนที่ต้อง
เป็นคนดีนะถือศีลอย่างเงี้ยค่ะก็คือก็จะ
มีแบบเทพเจ้ามาอยู่ที่ตัวเองแล้วก็
อแล้วก็นะทำให้ตัวเองแบบทำใช้เหล็กแหลม
แทงแก้มบ้างลิ้นมั่งอะไรอย่างเงี้ยเออนะ
พอเค้าไปอัญเชิญสันเจ้าใช่มั้ยแล้วพพอ
เอ่อมีเข้าทรงเเขาจะตีๆปุ๊บคนจะรู้ะว่า
ว่าเข้าทรงะเขาจะเปลี่ยนชุดใส่ชุดเป็นแบบ
เค่ะที่เห็นแบบชุดแบบเนี้ยอันเนี้ย
อันเนี้ยเป็นหม้าสร่งจะแต่งชุดไม่เหมือน
คนอื่นเห็นมั้ยคะมีแบบเป็นเอี๊ยมใส่เป็น
เอี๊ยมแดง
เหมือน
แบบแดงทองอ่ะเหมือนเทพเจ้าจีนนะคะ
ใช่บางคนก็เป็นเทพนินจาเทพนินจาก็คือไม่
ใช่นาจาูชิเออนาจานินจานัญี่ปุ่นนะค่ะเทพ
นาจาสมมุติเทพนาจาเข้าคนนี้ก็จะทำตัวแบบ
นาจาก็จะเป็นเด็มัดจุกอย่างงี้มั้ยแล้วก็
ต้องแบบเอี๊ยมสีแดงมยใช่แล้วก็จะเหมือน
กับชอบทำท่าแบบคือจะมีท่าประจำของเทพแต่
ละองค์ไงเทพที่แบบเอ่อเซียนที่เข้ามาเป็น
แบบแบบเซียนเซียนอะไรเซียนพัดก็จะชอบแบบ
ไปก็จะแบบให้พรต่างๆแบบเนี้ย
อืก็ต้องถือพัดใช่มั้ยแล้วก็พัดตัวเองใช่
มั้แต่ม้าทรงหลายๆคนก็จะจะใช้วิธีการที่
แบบโชว์อิทธิฤทธิ์เอาเหล็กแหลมทิ่มบางที
เอาร่มอ่ะร่มชายหาดใหญ่ๆค่ะกุกปุ๊กิ่มไป
ทะลุหวาดเสียวมากค่ะที่ภูเก็ติไม่เอาภาพ
มาค่ะใช่ค่ะเพราะว่ามันน่ากลัวบางคนคือ
เขาอยากให้เห็นไงว่าโอ้โหเทพเจ้าที่เข้า
มาเนี่ยแบบอิทฤทธิ์แบบมีความแบบ
ศักดิ์สิทธิ์มากๆเนาะนะแล้วก็บางคนเนี่ย
มีแอปเปิ้ลด้วยนะชิ่มิ่มเสร็จแล้วมี
แอปเปิ้ลห้อยเนี่ยให้ดับมามีมีผ้าเดี๋ยว
นี้มี่าเชื้ออะไเรียบร้อยค่ะอืก่อนเเหล็ก
ยังเป็นแบบโหเอาด้ำร่มที่ยังใช้อยู่เอามา
ทิ่มอะไรอย่างเงี้ยบางทีอาจจะเป็นบาทยัก์
ได้เขาก็เลย
บาทยานตาลน้ำตาลที่ร่มอ่ะแล้วมันเป็นมัน
เข้ามาในร่างกายในในในเลือดของเราหมอต้อง
ฉีดยาค่ะอน่ากลัวค่ะนะครูชิเอาอันที่น้อย
ที่สุดมาให้ดูแล้วค่ะเนี่ยน้อยที่สุดค่ะ
บางคนมีเก้าอี้ค่ะเอาเก้าอี้มาห้อยมีมีมี
เหล็กใหญ่ๆแบบใหญ่ขนาดนี้ค่ะทิ่มเสร็จ
แล้วก็เอาเก้าอี้มาห้อย 2 ข้างเอาแก้มแบก
แบกเก้าอี้ก็มีค่ะอ้านะเก้าอี้ที่เรานั่ง
เนี่ยนะครูชิใช่ค่ะถ้านักเรียนอยากดูก็ไป
เสิร์ชหาภาพดูค่ะมันหวาดเสียวเกินนะคะ
กลัวแล้วก็อันนี้ก็จะมีการจุดประทัดค่ะ
อันนี้ก็เป็นเรื่องสนุกของเด็กๆเห็นมั้ย
คะเด็กๆก็จะมาดูประทัดอันไหนที่มันยังไม่
ระเบิดแล้วก็เอามาจุดแล้วก็โยนเล่นระเบิด
โออันตรายเนาะอืเด็กๆเาก็สนุกไงคนไหนโยน
ทันก็ไม่เป็นไรคนไหนโยนไม่ทันก็นิ้ว
หายนะอันนี้ก็ต้องหห้ามลูกหลานเนาะอ่ะอัน
นี้อะไรคะครูชิอันนี้โรงเจก็คือแบบเอ่อ
สันเจ้าเนี่ยก็จะมีโรงอาหารของเขาคเขาคก็
จะมีการทำอาหารทีแบบเยอะๆสำหรับเลี้ยงคน
แจกคนคนไหนที่ไม่มีอาหารกินเนี่ยก็ไปที่
โรงเจค่ะกินฟรีออถ้านักเรียนมาช่วงกินเจ
นะไปที่โรงเจกินฟรีค่ะใช่ค่ะแล้วนักเรียน
อยากจะให้เงินก็เอาไปหยอด้ได้ค่ะนะเพราะ
ว่าก็เหมือนกับทำบุญนะเพื่อเอาเงินเนี้ย
ไปซื้ออาหารซื้อของมาทำอาหารแล้วก็ส่งต่อ
ให้คนหลายๆคนเนที่เบางคนน่ะไม่มีเงินซื้อ
ข้าวกินก็มากินได้ค่ะนะแล้วก็กินเจเเนี่ย
มันกินยังไงอ่ะคะครู
ชิตอนเนี้ยถ้าเกิดไปร้านอาหารแล้วมีธงสี
เหลืองแบบเนี้ยค่ะอันนี้คือร้านนี้ขาย
อาหารเจค่ะโอ้โหคนก็เยอะเห็นมั้ยคะนะแล้ว
ร้านอาหารเจอ่ะขายดีมากครูปุ๊บนะอาหารเจ
ก็คืออาหารที่จะไม่มีเนื้อสัตว์ใช่มั้ยคะ
นะใช่ค่ะครูไม่มีเนื้อสัตว์แล้วก็บางคน
อาจจะแบบไม่มีผักนะผักที่มีกลิ่นเา้าบอก
ว่ากลิ่นแรงๆหรือว่าเราเรียกว่ากลิ่นฉุน
น่ะก็ไม่มีนะก็จะงไปด้วยเชกระเทียม
แหรือว่าผักชีหรือครึนไ่เนาะก็คือเหมือน
นักเรียนมีซาลารี่อ่ะมันจะคล้ายๆกับขึืน
ใช่ประเทศไทยเนาะนะกลิ่นมันจะแรงแบบกลิ่น
ฉุนเขาบอกว่าอันเนี้ยบางคนเขาจะไม่ใส่เลย
นะถึงมันจะเป็นผักก็เหอะนะแล้วก็เนื้อ
สัตว์เนี่ยก็คือเป็นเทศกาลที่ไม่กินเนื้อ
สัตว์ค่ะค่ะอนะก็ดีนะคะูชิ
ใช่ค่ะแล้วก็โอ้โหแบบดูคนกินเจสิครู
ปุ๊กเมื่อวานเพิ่งเริ่มกินนะคะคนเนี่ย
โอ้โหคิวอาหารเจเนี่ยคนขายดิบขายดีค่ะนะค
ฝ่ายครัวเนี่ยคะทำกันไม่หยุดค่ะด้านหน้า
ก็มีคนซื้อกินแล้วก็ซื้อกลับบ้านนะคะบาง
คนอาจจะกินไม่ไม่ใช่กินเพราะว่าเอ่อถือ
ศีลเหมือนกับเอ่อคนอื่นๆบางคนอาจจะกินตอน
นี้กินเพื่อสุขภาพก็มีใช่มั้ยครูอ่าใช่
ค่ะแล้วก็มันเป็นเทศกาลที่เราสามารถหา
อาหารเจกินง่ายไงกูชิไปที่ไหนก็มีอาหารเจ
แต่ถ้าในชช่วงปกติไม่มีเทศกาลเนี่ยเราอาจ
จะหายากหน่อยค่ะอร้านอาหารเจเเนี่ยอาจจะ
มี
น้อยนะทีเนี้ยการกินการเราได้กินอาหารเจเ
เนี่ยอาหารเจเองก็มีพัฒนาการนะพัฒนาการก็
คือเอ่อมีการเอ่อเปลี่ยนจากเดิมซึ่งเมื่อ
ก่อนอาจจะกินแค่เห็ดกินเต้าหู้ตอนเนี้ย
เข้าเอาเต้าหู้ค่ะมาทำให้เหมือนเนื้อเนาะ
เนี่ยเหมือนเนื้อสัตว์ค่ะโอ้โหเหมือนคุณ
กินสเต็กอันนี้เหมือนเนื้อหมูใช่มยหรือ
ว่าบางทีเนี่ยจะเป็นแบบโอ้โหขาเหมือนขา
ไก่เลยค่ะน่องไก่ค่ะนี่อ้า
คุชิเหมือนกินเหมือนกินเหมือนกินอะไรนะขา
ไก่แต่ตัดออกมาเนี่ยเป็นเหมือนกับเอ่อ
เป็นเป็นอะไรนะโปรตีนเกษตรค่ะโปรตีนเกษตร
ใช่ทำมาจากถั่วเหลืองนั่นแหละค่ะค่ะใช่
ค่ะก็คือโปรตีนที่มาจากพวกถั่วหรือธัญพืช
เนาะนะเป็นโปรตีนที่ไม่ได้มาจากเนื้อ
สัตว์ค่ะนะแต่ทำให้ดูเนี่ยมันเหมือนกับ
โอ๊เวลากินเนี่ยเราก็จะรู้สึกเหมือนกิน
ไก่ค่ะนะแล้วก็รสชาติเนี่ยหรือว่ากลิ่น
เนี่ยเมีแต่งบางทีก็เหมือนมากค่ะกูชินะม
คะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยการกินเจเเนี่ยแม้แต่
กินเจเพื่อสุขภาพภาพเนี่ยก็ยังมีการให้มี
ความสวยงามน่ากินมีการประดิษฐ์สร้างสรรค์
งานอาหารเนี่ยให้ดูน่ากินเพราะฉะนั้นเห็น
มยเจก็กินได้แต่ว่านักเรเทเรียนก็ได้
มังสวิรัตก็กินได้อ่าวีแกนก็กินได้ด้วยคน
ที่ไม่กินเนื้อสัตว์นะกินแต่กินกินไม่กิน
เนื้อสัตว์เลยก็กินได้เห็นมยฮะอปฏิเสธเษ
เนื้อสัตว์ก็กินได้นะอาหารเจเดี๋ยวนี้
โอ้โหมีหลากหลายเมนูค่ะครูปุ๊กนะก็เหม
เหมือนเมนูปกติที่เรากินเนาะเพียงแต่ว่า
ทำเป็นเจก็คือไม่มีเนื้อสัตว์เท่านั้นเอง
ใชใส่เข้าไปอย่างอันเนี้ยต้มยำเมื่อก่อน
เป็นต้มยำกุ้งพอกินเจก็กลายเป็นต้มยำเห็ด
นะแล้วก็เห็ดหลายๆอย่างด้วยนะคะครูชิใช่
ค่ะนะหรืออะไรนะแบบ
อันเนี้ยแบบมีผักน้ำมันหอยหลายๆอย่างนะ
ผัดน้ำมันหอยนะมีปอกเปี๊ยทอดมีหมี่ใช่ผัด
หมี่แล้วก็อันนี้คือที่ครูชิชอบค่ะเวลา
กินเจทีไรครูชิจะชอบอาหารพวกนี้ชอบอาหาร
ทอดค่ะถั่วดำชุบแป้งทอดเผือกทอดเต้าหู้
ทอดข้าวโพด
ทอดหัวใช้เท้าทอดตัวใช้เท้าทอดก็อร่อย
อร่อยหมดเลยอ่ะใช่ค่ะแล้วก็มีน้ำจิ้มค่ะเ
ไม่ได้กินเปล่าๆนะมันต้องมีน้ำจิ้มจิ้ม
กินด้วยค่ะมันจะออกรสหวานๆเปรี้ยวๆนะมัน
จะอร่อยดีค่ะนะซึ่งตอนช่วงไม่ไม่มีเทศกาล
กินเจเหากินยากมากใช่ค่ะแต่ช่วงเทศกาลกิน
เจเนี่ยจะมีเยอะนะคะอย่างหัวใช้เท้าทอด
เนี่ยโอ้โหกว่าจะได้เจะเอาเอหัวใช้เท้าไป
ขูดให้เป็นเส้นก่อนใช่มยแล้วก็มาคุกทำผสม
รสชาติเสร็จแล้วมาห่อที่เอ่อฟองเต้าหู้
ค่ะฟองเต้าหู้ก็เป็นน้ำถั่วเหลืองที่เรา
กินน้ำเต้าหู้อ่ะค่ะแล้วก็แผ่นข้างบนเขา
จะเอามาเป็นฟองเต้าหู้นะเขาเขียนชิ้นละ 45
บาทค่ะอืเลือกไปเลยอยากจะกินชิ้นไหนก็
เลือกไปค่ะชิ้นละ 45 บาทแล้วเก็ไปหั่นมี
น้ำจิให้กินอืออันนี้เนี่ยดูแล้วหน้าตา
เหมือนข้าวมันไก่เลยข้าวมันไก่ทอดค่ะกูชิ
โอ้โหนะแต่อันนี้ไม่ใช่ไก่แต่เป็นโปรตีน
กเษตร
นแต่ก็ทำให้ดูเหมือนเนาะบางคนอาจจะแบบรู้
สึกแบบโอยังยังแบบกินยากอยู่เนาะแบบ
อื้อหือก็อ่ะอย่างน้อยเอ้อเห็นรูปร่าง
หน้าตาเหมือนกันก็น่าจะชอบ
ค่ะอันเนี้ยเป็นการดึงคนที่กินทั่วๆไปมา
ลองกินเจด้วยทำให้ในประเทศไทยเนี่ยมีคน
กินเจมากขึ้นทุกปีเพราะว่าวิธีการทำอาหาร
เจในประเทศไทยมันทำให้คนอยากมาลองกินหน้า
ตามันก็เหมือนกับอาหารที่เรากินทั่วๆไปอื
นะนะนักเรียนดูสิอมีเต้าหู้มีวุ้นเส้นมี
เห็มีเห็ดอืนะมีแครอทอ่าแล้วก็มีผักอืนะ
กะลัมปี้เนาะโอหลายอย่างค่ะนะครบถ้วนใน
จานเดียวค่ะถ้วนแล้วก็ใช้ซีอิวค่ะอันนี้
ก็เป็นต้มยำเห็ดอ้าูชิชิเปลี่ยนตามเเห็น
ครูปุ๊กยังพูดอยู่เลยถอยไปให้นะอันนี้
เห็นมั้ยคะต้มยำเห็ดเจค่ะอ๋อแล้วเห็ด
อันเนี้ยน่ากินมากค่ะเพราะว่าเป็นเห็ดฟาง
เห็ดฟางเนี่ยมันจะเป็นลูกเล็กๆเนน่ากิน
อร่อยค่ะนะอื้อหือต้มยำ
โอ้โหปกติเในต้มยำกุ้งเนาะก็มีเห็ดอย่าง
เงี้ยเราก็เลือกกินเห็ดเหมือน
กัน่อันนี้ครูชิชอบค่ะอันนี้พะโล้เจค่ะ
โอ้โหเต้าหู้เป็นเต้าหู้แล้วก็มีแบบเห็น
คนที่ชอบกินอะไรที่มันมีหนึบๆใช่มั้ยก็
ต้องใส่อืโปรตีนเกษตรเข้าไปมันก็จะเหมือน
กับเนื้อสัตว์เนื้อสัตว์ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าได้
โปรตีนเหมือนกันเนาะนะแต่ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยที่
ชอบในเนี้ยก็คือชอบเห็ดหอมค่ะเห็ดหอมนี่
ใช่มั้ยเห็ดหอมใช่ค่ะเห็ดหอมนะเป็นเห็ด
เห็ดสดอ่ะค่ะแล้วก็เอ้ยเห็ดแห้งเนาะแล้วเ
ก็ไปแแช่น้ำแล้วก็เอามาต้มนะปุนชอบเห็ด
หอมค่ะอื้อหือแล้วก็มีเต้าหู้นะเต้าหู้
ไม่ชอบค่ะออันนี้อืโปรตีนเกษตรหน้าตา
เหมือนกับเนื้อหมูเหมือนกันนะใช่เทำให้
เหมือนไงจะได้แบบคนที่ยังทำใจเลิกออเลิก
เนื้อสัตว์ไม่ได้อย่างน้อยก็เห็นแล้วมัน
เหมือน
อ่านะว่ายังมีเนื้อสัตว์อยู่เนาะ
อ่านะอันนี้ก็แบบเอ่อครูชิเรียกมันว่าผัด
หมี่เจจริงๆก็คือผัดยากิโซบะนั่นแหละค่ะ
แต่คนจีนน่ะจะผัดอันเนี้ยเยอะที่เป็นเส้น
ใหญ่ๆแบบนี้เหมือนยากิโซบะนะฮูชิจะเห็น
เค้าขายมากๆในช่วงกินเจูชิก็เลยจะเรียก
มันว่าผัดหมี่เจผัดหมี่เจใช่ค่ะแล้วก็มัน
จะมีเส้นเล็กกว่านี้ไงคูชิมันก็จะมีผัด
มันก็จะมีอีกอันนึงที่เส้นมันเล็กกว่านี้
ก็ผัดแล้วก็ช่วงเทศกาลกินเจเราจะหากินได้
ง่ายแต่ว่าพอไม่ใช่เทศกาลกินเจเเนี่ยไม่
เห็นเลย
ค่ะใช่มยมีทุกร้านค่ะและแน่นอนที่ขาดไม่
ได้ค่ะผัดผักค่ะผัดผักรวมมิตรค่ะแปลว่า
รวมเพื่อนๆของผักมาด้วยนะมีหลายอย่างเนาะ
ใส่ด้วยกันนะแต่เค้าก็ไม่ใช้ซอสน้ำมันหอย
นะใช้แต่ซีอิ๊วขาวใช่มยใช่ใส่แต่ซีอิ๊ว
แล้วก็อาจจะใส่ใส่แป้งข้าวโพดนิดๆอ่าให้
มันเหนียวๆในะคะโอ้ยอันนี้สิอร่อยโหยเต้ม
ผักอันเนี้ยค่ะผักกะหล่ำเนี่ยค่ะกะหล่ำปี
ต้มจนแบบนิ่มแบบเนิ่มมากๆจะขายเป็นหัวเลย
เลยนะบางทีเนี่ยหัวเล็กๆอ่ะแล้วก็แบบ
โอ้โหต้มทั้งหัวเลยแหละเวลาตักก็ตักหัว
ใหญ่ๆหัวนึงเลยอ่ะแล้วพอมาหั่นเนี่ย
อื้อหือนิ่มทั้งหัวค่ะกินอร่อยค่ะอร่อย
ยิ่งยิ่งยิ่งอุ่นนานๆยิ่งนิ่มมากๆก็ยิ่ง
อร่อยนะเพราะว่าซุปมันด้วยเนาะซุปมันก็
อร่อยโอ้โหอันเนี้ยว่ากินเจกินผัดกะเพรา
ไม่ได้หรอคะกินผัดกะเพราได้เอาเห็ดอันนี้
เมีเห็ดนะแล้วก็มีเหมือนกับเต้าโปรตีน
เกษตรแล้วก็โปรตีนเกษตรใช่มั้ยใช่เอามาทำ
ให้เหมือนเนื้อสัตว์หรือว่าเป็นตับเป็น
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยเนาะแล้วก็มาผัดกระเพราผัด
กระเพราค่ะใช่ค่ะนะก็เพราะว่าคนเรามันก็
นะคนไทยยเนี่ยติดรสชาติไงถ้าจืดๆเนี่ยกิน
ไม่ได้แบบมันเลี่ยนไงน้ำมันเยอะมันจะรู้
สึกแบบเลี่ยนหมายถึงว่าเวลาน้ำมันเยอะๆ
เรากินแล้วเราจะรู้สึกแบบเอ่อมันจะผอืด
พอมท้องไม่สบายนะอยากจะเอาออกอะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะเขาเรียกว่ามันเลี่ยนนะก็ถ้ากิน
แบบมีพริกมีเผ็ดๆหน่อยนะมันจะลดการเลี่ยน
ไม่ทำให้เราเลี่ยนน้ำมันนะก็เลยเป็นสิ่ง
ที่คนไทยเนี่ยก็เลยจะต้องใส่ลงไปด้วยค่ะ
คือต้องมีรสเผ็ดด้วยค่ะนะแกเรียนทีเนี้ย
การกินเจในประเทศไทยเนี่ยคนเนี่ยมีความ
นิยมกินมากขึ้นเรื่อยๆครูชิเห็นนะคะหลายๆ
คนเนี่ยก็มีเป้าหมายก็คือเหมือนกับว่ากิน
เพื่ออะไรนะคะทำไมกินอืไปกินเจนะก็นะก็
หลายๆคนก็คิดว่าอ๋อเพราะว่าทำบุญค่ะดูชิ
ศาสนาพุทธช่วงเวลาช่วงนึงก็ไม่กินเนื้อ
สัตว์ไม่เบียดเบียนก็คือไม่ฆ่าเพราะว่า
ถ้าเรากินเนื้อสัตว์คนก็จะฆ่าสัตว์เยอะใน
ช่วงนั้นช่วงที่แบบว่ามีเทพเจ้าลงมาเราจะ
ทำดี
ค่ะถ้าเทพเจ้าไม่ลงมาเราก็กินเนื้อสัตว์
ใช่มั้ยงเทพช่วงนี้เทพเจ้าจะลงมาค่ะจะมา
ดูว่ามีใครทำดีก็จะให้พรใช่มั้ยพอเทพเจ้า
เหมือนเหมือนนักเรียนไนักเรียนเนี่ยพอ
เวลาครูมาขยันเรียนอ่าเวลาครูออกไปปุ๊บ
บางคนนอนบางคนคุยอือเป็นอย่างงั้นเหรอคะ
ใช่นะช่วงนี้เทพเจ้าจะลงมาทุกคนก็เป็นคน
ดีค่ะอืก็ไม่เบียดเบียนเนื้อสัตว์ไม่ฆ่า
สัตว์ไม่กินบางคนเพราะว่ามีเทพเจ้าเป็น
ความเชื่อนะว่าเทพเทพเจ้าเนี่ยจะลงมาตรวจ
สอบว่าใครเป็นคนดีบ้างใครเป็นคนไม่ดีอะไร
อย่างงี้นะแต่ว่าบางคนอาจจะรู้สึกว่าใน 1
ปีอ่ะเราแบ่งสัก 10 วันนะที่ไม่กินเนื้อ
สัตว์ก็จะทำให้สัตว์เนี่ยถูกฆ่าน้อยลงนะ
ก็อาจจะเป็นการทำบุญอย่างนึงนะนนะหรือว่า
บางคนเนี่ยรู้สึก
ว่าสุขภาพต้องแข็งแรงนะกินเนื้อสัตว์มากๆ
เนี่ยนะก็อาจจะเป็นอันตรายกับสุขภาพเยอะ
ก็ได้ใช่มเพราะว่าตอนนี้เนี่ยก็เนื้อ
สัตว์ก็มีเคมีบ้างมีอะไรบ้างเนาะเขาก็อาจ
จะแบบรู้สึกว่าต้อง
ลดลดการกินเนื้อสัตว์อย่างน้อยก็ 10 วัน
ก็ได้นะทำให้สุขภาพแข็งแรงเพราะว่าเรามอง
ว่าคนเนี่ยเป็นคนที่เค้าดูจากฟันใช่มั้ย
ว่าฟันเราเนี่ยมันน่ามันไม่ใช่เป็นฟันที่
สำหรับกินเนื้อสัตว์ค่ะกินผักแต่คนเนี่ย
ฉลาดก็เลยกินเนื้อทุกอย่างได้นะคะเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยร่างกายเราก็ย่อยอาหารที่เป็น
เนื้อสัตว์แล้วเนี่ยมันจะมันจะทำงานหนัก
ก็ต้องมีการหยุดให้ร่างกายเนี่ยพักเบอก
ว่าล้างท้องล้างท้องก็คือเอาพวกเคมีเอา
พวกเนื้อสัตว์ที่แบบคือคนที่กินเนื้อ
สัตว์อ่ะคุณกุ๊กสังเกตมั้ยคนที่กินเนื้อ
สัตว์เนี่ยกลิ่นตัวคนเาจะมีกลิ่นตัวของ
เนื้อสัตว์มันจะมีเรื่องของการเนื้อสัตว์
เนี่ยมันอยู่ในร่างกายเรามันจะอือยู่นานๆ
มันก็จะเหม็นไง
อือ๋อครูปุกรู้แลเหมือนคนที่กินหมาหรือ
ว่าสุนัขเบางคนเค้ากินใช่มยเวลาไปที่ไหน
มีหมาหๆเห็นมันจะได้กลิ่นค่ะแล้วมันก็จะ
เห่าจะแบบแหแจะขู่ด้วยนะบางบางตัวขี้กลัว
ก็หนีค่ะอือนะอ่าแสดงว่าเรากินอะไรก็จะมี
กลิ่นแบบนั้นใช่ค่ะครูใช่ค่ะอืเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยตอนนี้เนี่ยกินเจไม่ใช่เพื่อ
ทำบุญอย่างเดียวยังมีกลุ่มคนที่กินเพราะ
ว่าสุขภาพร่างกายให้ร่างกายเนี่ยให้
กระเพาะเนี่ยไม่ไม่ต้องมีเนื้อสัตว์สัก
ช่วงหนึเป็นการล้างท้องให้สะอาด
ให้สะอาด
นะเห็นมบางคนก็เลยไปใส่ชุดขาวนะถือศีลกิน
เจนะก็เหมือนกับปตัวดีใช่ค่ะนะมี 365 วัน
เอาสัก 10 วันนะเป็นคน
ดีอันนี้เริ่มสตาร์ทก่อนบางคนกินแล้วชอบ
ก็กินยาวใช่กินตลอดไปเลยก็มีใช่ก็มีค่ะนะ
แต่ในช่วงเทศกาลกินเจเนี่ยก็อาหารเจก็หา
กินได้ง่ายทุกซอกทุกซอยมีค่ะนะมาประเทศ
ไทยนักเรียนก็จะได้กินเจแบบโอโหอาหารเยอะ
แยะค่ะแล้วก็อร่อยค่ะนะแต่ถ้าอยากจะลอง
กินโดยที่ไม่ต้องซื้อก็ไปที่โรงเจค่ะที่
มีศาลเจ้าจีนนะคะก็ไปที่นั่นจะมีอาหารให้
กินฟรีค่ะอร่อยด้วยค่ะค่ะวันนี้หมดเวลา
แล้วเราเราต้องไปแล้วค่ะต้องไปกินเจกัน
ค่ะไปกินฟรีอ้าไม่
ใช่งั้นต้องลานักเรียนแล้วนะคะสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบายบ๊ายบายค่ะ